welcome to this video and yeah playing
again a teammate of mine let's see what
we what we get we are we are very very
close in rating over the board also 2400
rated international master can look at
the name yet Tomas color from Dusseldorf
young nudists poop where I live ok we
have a queen's gambit exchange and 0 is
playing the the main line not night h5
let's see there are many many different
setups this is one of them with age
three hmm do you kiss a long or short
here i am castling long i think i can
cancel long now that was quickly played
is there is there a form i-94 i mean
this might be might be a move ok
still hard to play without the King here
hmm yeah black black blazer or wants to
play a quick c5 I think I should take
some precautions against that with night
be three I I know I'm getting this night
away from the kingside wear my players
but I want to prevent c5c five now looks
dubious because of might be three and
getting this on c5 the bishop pair
mostly okay a good night be three here
let's do that then maybe g4 it's more
like that's it I just want to win space
I don't think it's so the start of a
deadly attack who maybe I should switch
to the queenside entirely now after a
six this weekend c5 now be six is
probably entirely I was about to say
entirely unplayable but ok bishop asics
ruka head is a problem so I take here ok
aight Queenie to this be five if I go
back what is he doing after that if I go
back put the subject now now a sexy a6
really Hanks and on a five I have Bishop
a six yeah but I guess this was
necessary if I go Queenie to now does
this provoke be five
I'm thinking far too long here need to
speed up let's let's see a fight i'm
going nite a 4 again probably okay
that's that's a sharpest way to play so
i cannot really take here because of c-4
missing many things here okay i need to
do something else that switch the
attention to the d5 pawn complicated
position
hmm yeah don't really like it
can light takes problems no yeah it's
not that clear both made some sense okay
maybe I can get the come into G for me
if he takes on g5 i take c 5 I need some
activity battling at least he cannot
advance the pawns easily before Hank c4
that's not deform yeah but still I was I
don't want to give up a pawneean for
some activity on the G file should I
play F for community let's let's do that
one minute left that's not good
Knight to e5 somehow not sure 1965 if I
have this night XD hive some maybe i can
double on the g file yeah that's still
fairly complicated it's it should be of
course good for black but its own i have
some some sort of activity Knight to e5
not sure about that but
hmm Nyjah for would be nice somehow
naija form something like that okay
30 seconds
that's really the biggest problem here
the position is of course better for
black but I guess laughs chances here
because I'm reasonably reasonably active
but 30 seconds right the eight is a
funny fork take on c5 very little time
time morning check 13 seconds check
check Gras offered draw offered game
yeah okay I'm not sure even if he did
some chance to win on time FB is not
very quick at the end very tough game
and of course i was i was worse most of
the time it says I'm pretty quick yeah I
can be quick sometimes at least at at
the end of the games a very tough game I
was really a really not in good shape
here around here it feels it fits really
unclear to me I don't know maybe it's
just bad because he has got this this
rather big Center I think this was
probably unjustified he can really take
it you can really take it down it's not
easy to play because of this strong PCM
but I'm struggling f5 or so away five
this is I missed yeah that's a very good
very good move this is this is very good
for wide even champion this year where
do you go I it just runs into a big
attack iam thanks
yeah five is a good move really I had to
add some compensation but it's not
sufficient really he defended well I
mean did I what the others was of course
very much influenced by the time
situation cackles need to dash out some
moves yeah this was what it was a funny
/ side I probably should should be okay
now you know I'm an exchange up but it's
not not so easy to play this is maybe
better yeah I really don't know yeah I
should probably take check but ok I've
got 20 seconds i think i played this
reasonably well getting the exchange bag
and this end game is just better provide
of course you cannot expect to to see a
precise play here this is of course
something I should I should just win but
of course the time situation here I
probably just be five okay I've got five
seconds this this is winning these bones
the sports just just promote he has no
way to stop it really I just support
them with the King and I can always
return this just look for the pond yeah
very tough fighting game thanks for
watching